thanks for staying with us at 4 30. i'm
vanessa murphy and i'm christian casadas
a las vegas man is under arrest after a
wild police chase this happening in
california and get this he was inside an
amazon delivery van police say quentin
larks faces multiple charges including
two home invasion robberies and he has a
criminal history here in southern nevada
a wild police chase in this carjacked
amazon delivery van in riverside
california police say 32-year-old
quentin larks drove the wrong way and
hit at least three vehicles as he
barreled through city streets in an
attempt to evade them all right he's
going over the center divider unit c on
the right side we got it for you wrong
side of the road they were chasing him
after he was suspected in two home
invasion robberies this last collision
left the van undrivable
really bad again into another truck
vehicle is going to be disabled and he
was arrested after an unsuccessful
attempt to climb the vines on this
barrier wall
larks is no stranger to the law he has
at least four arrests in las vegas
including burglary charges and a
domestic violence conviction he served
time for in 2012 and a theft conviction
in 2019. there were no serious injuries
reported to any of the people who were
attacked robbed or crashed into his new
charges are attempted murder home
invasion robbery carjacking dui and
reckless evading of police
larks is being held in riverside on a 1
million dollar bail